hey youtubers it's Charlie so this week
for my Game of Thrones bonus video I
wanted to talk about White Walkers
something really cool happened on the
set so this is gonna be a little bit of
speculation based on past experience so
the really cool thing that happened is
is that the people that shot the big
white Walker scenes last year like
during hardhome are heading to the set
so they're actually getting ready to do
some white Walker stuff now because we
haven't read winds of winter we're kind
of an unspoiled territory so a lot of
this is going to be speculation based on
stuff they've been setting up in the
previous books and the previous seasons
in the show so just careful for spoilers
for everything that's happened on the
show so far and new round of the
giveaway starts now - it's just a $20
Amazon gift card all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so here we go
what are some of the biggest things that
could happen with White Walkers in
episode 10 well the night's king could
show up at the wall or we could just get
a really ominous scene that deep into
the mythology of White Walkers there's
still so much that we don't know about
the great other like we don't know
really anything about their culture
george RR martin just hasn't written in
the end someone actually asked them
previously if they have culture and he's
like I'm not sure I mean this was like a
year ago so he may have changed that
since then but if you ever weren't sure
there are certain things that George R
Martin makes up as he goes along I mean
he has a pretty good idea where he wants
the characters ahead like he knows about
the character arts but there are certain
things that he thinks of as he goes
along that's why by the time the
characters get to a dream of spring they
could be doing vastly different things
than the characters on the show do in
season eight but just looking back at
previous seasons episode ten has
typically been reserved for wrapping up
storylines in a way that throws into the
next season you still get some big
reveals like last season arya went blind
but the closest thing we've had to a big
battle in episode 10 was Stannis going
up against the Bolton's and that really
wasn't much of a big battle there was
more of lambs going to slaughter
actually I'll go ahead and say season
four when Stannis showed up with the
cell source that was a bigger battle
because there was actual fighting but
does that mean we're gonna see like a
white Walker version of what happened to
Stannis at the end of season five like
will the White Walkers just show up and
eat whatever army is near the wall not
necessarily but I do like the idea that
they would end with a big white Walker
victory at the end of season six just to
try and avoid rampant spoilers I'll say
you know there's supposed to be a big
battle in the north that could lead to
like a really high moment for
good characters so why not end on a
really WTF down moment when White
Walkers completely destroy something now
I will say I think it's a little early
for the wall to be coming down but I do
think that they would do that WTF moment
the thing is is that the local
government where the wall scenes are
filmed wants Game of Thrones wants HBO
to keep the wall up so they can use it
as a tourist attraction it's just super
popular I mean of course people want to
go visit the wall so I think they're
gonna try and leave it up as long as
possible but I do think at a certain
point like they'll be the epic CG moment
where the night's king just brings it
crashing down it's kind of like watching
the golden harpy come tumbling down the
pyramid during season five any time a
story presents like this big shiny
symbol of power of course it has to come
tumbling down at a certain point but
it's white walkers do make it to the
wall and there's a battle in and around
that area then what does that mean for
season 7 well it means that they're
victorious of course they're gonna push
south during season 7 and and I've said
in the past I think I would love to see
denier show up at like the end of season
7 so that season 8 can be like this
giant prolonged battle season but a lot
of that will just depend on the pacing
of season 6 like we'll just have to have
wait till we get episodes to see how
fast they're trying to speed things
along if they really wanted to I mean
they could stretch it out to like 12
seasons but they've already said they
don't want to do that so I guess it just
depends on how literal you think
Daenerys has visions from the house of
the undying are like she makes it to the
Iron Throne but it's covered in falling
snow so that would mean that White
Walkers have pushed very far south by
the time Daenerys gets to Westeros I try
not to be too literal when it comes to
things like that
I definitely think we'll see White
Walkers in the south like they'll be the
reason for all the people that hate each
other in Westeros to come together but
remember Daenerys has visions were also
of things that could have happened had
things been different though she saw a
future vision of her baby Rago the one
who would mount the world but we know
he's dead we'll call that Game of
Thrones earth too but mostly what I'm
hoping with this white Walker stuff in
episode 10 you know whatever ends up
going on is that we're just gonna see a
lot of white Walker stuff in season
seven as of where we are in the books
right now winter has already come so the
further south that it pushes like the
colder and colder it gets the more White
Walkers we have to see I know some of
you have asked me in the past like if
the White Walkers bring the cold or if
they follow the cold and I think it's
this cyclical relationship
like there's general climate change and
the White Walkers are just taking
advantage of that but there might also
be some magic and play we don't know
quite how powerful the night's king is
only that he has mast powers of
necromancy now any white Walker can
raise a white the night's king is just
presumably more powerful like he can
just raise several all at the same time
and there have been a lot of theories
about what's gonna happen with the
night's king and if there's going to be
some sort of truce in the final battle I
definitely think there won't be an
absolute final victory like they'll just
beat the White Walkers back to the lands
of always winter just to talk about this
character here the night's king that
they used during Episode eight George R
Martin clarified that the classic
night's King the thirteenth Lord
Commander is probably dead so the term
night's King if you want to use that is
like a title that gets passed down it's
just used to distinguish this character
from the other White Walkers if you have
the night's king then you have normal
White Walkers then you have all the
whites that they've raised to serve them
and for those of you that are still
holding out for benjin this is the actor
that plays that night's king that they
use so he'll probably be back in season
eight definitely not Joseph malli looks
absolutely nothing like the actor that
plays Benjen but the really cool thing
about all this is that they're bringing
brand stark back we're gonna get a lot
of brand scenes we're gonna get a lot of
Bloodraven scenes so that will probably
tie in with what's going on with these
White Walkers the Bloodraven is one of
the few characters we haven't seen a
whole lot with him yet but he's one of
the few characters that's lived long
enough to accumulate the knowledge that
we need like we is the audience and that
the characters need in order to fight
the White Walkers so everybody get hype
and here's my big question for you let
me know do you think that episode 10
white Walker stuff is going to be a big
battle like what's happened with Stannis
the last two seasons or do you think
it's just going to be an ominous reveal
like they'll just show up at the wall
and then BAM slam to black well I guess
think about that I'll say
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner Stannis the man is Baratheon it
was actually an HBO reveal about what's
going on with your character I don't
want to right here just because it's
super spoilery but it pretty much
definitively answers whether he is alive
or dead please stand his private message
me on the back end of my channel so I
get your contact info just in case you
guys haven't seen it a whole bunch of
Star Wars stuff that's been going on the
last week I posted a couple trailers
couple clips you can click here to see
all those and you can
here for all my Game of Thrones Season
six bonus videos thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight
you